we're gonna go on air all right let's
see if this works what up guys what up
what up am I live am I live let's see if
it's working
uh um
let's see let's see
excuse my dog
in the background
am I not love it's like the oh I am I am
yay I got it guys I'm not too good at
the technology thing
so today was a busy day
busy busy busy I was very busy you know
I made some cookies from scratch I know
I know
um
I made
what else did I do
oh I made some law fries but the cheat
way and and
I
was busy with my my Handler
lots of handlers around here anyways I'm
not gonna focus on that so
um today I am going to be reacting to
um
you know different stuff and I was
thinking I was a bunch of watching It's
Complicated video and I was like why
don't I just react in person the OG
subscribers remember when I used to do a
million reaction videos also if you hear
noise in the background let me double
check that this is working I always
gotta check it on my phone
um
let me know in the chat
um okay let me
here it is here it is
it's working can you guys hear me can
you hear me all right I'm gonna I'm
having a hard time where I have to
blessing I need you to set it up okay
blessings my producer set it up where I
mean my Handler
um I need you to set it up where
you can put the chat on the screen
because right now I gotta look at my
phone to see the chat
um anyways I was watching
this so now blessing has made it very
complicated I used to just do stream
labs and it was very simple but now
we have very complicated
now oh gosh
you know
if my hair is messy it's because I was
thinking about it as part of my brand
anyways
um so what is is the audio off
the audio off it sounds really loud on
my on my thing I'm I'm gonna trust
something but I I don't want it to
okay let's see
um
all right I'm gonna start this over
because you guys so if you didn't know
I'm I watch it's complicated okay let me
turn on picture in picture
what the
I'm in myself oh
I forgot okay you gotta do it this way
ha ha ha
okay
um is there a cat in your room no but I
do have a dog
Ellie you're so loud
it's like
so loud so loud but it's okay
um
we're struggle streaming I mean
I do kind of miss the mic in front of me
because then it wouldn't really matter
what was going on around but
you can't we can't win them all
I wonder if watching these will make me
a better debater I feel like
all right I feel like there's some
YouTubers that all they do is sit and
like watch stuff all day and it honestly
makes them a better debater in my
opinion because instead of living life
I mean all they're doing is thinking
about the stuff anyways
um
Pearl you should date Nick what do you
think of him uh Nick is a nice guy but
guys
I'm like an old maid for that man look
at he's looking for an 18 year old
Italian version all right one I'd be too
white and two
old
and three
well you know
anyways so
unfortunately
didn't work out
um
let's see let's see
some other some other questions I'll
answer some questions real quick real
quick in the chat okay
um
Nick Flynn just had a rally today I did
not know I did not know
um
how bad is this this he said have you
seen my DMs guys I get so many DMS okay
I get so many
um
any other questions real quick real
quick
uh okay now all right I'm gonna I'm
gonna go back to the
back to the chat all right
[Music]
can you define accountability
to doubt it
just kidding I'm just kidding any
responsibility for your own action yes
whether you lie or tell the truth it's
all about just being honest with your
partner accountability to me is just
taking responsibility for your your own
actions making sure that you like when
you say you're gonna do something or you
say like something is important to you
that you follow up on on those things do
you hear the bass I can always tell
I don't know if it's like linked to
testosterone but more liberal or like
feminist answering guys they always tend
to have
that like feminism in their voice
ability is when I say I'm gonna do
something that I'm following through
accountability is follow through to me
who takes more accountability men or
women and why women oh my gosh no we do
not no ma'am I've interviewed hundreds
of women okay and I'll tell you how I
know we are not accountable okay
if you ask a woman what she did wrong in
her last relationship
it's always it's always
I cared too much I loved too hard blah
blah blah also also if any people that
have been on the show are watching this
you want to come by react with me I'm
going to be reacting for a minute so
feel free feel free
why
men try to hide [__] because they feel
like they're gonna
scare their women away or hurt them in
some way I've had a lot of guys tell me
they're gonna do something and it
doesn't happen
uh I'm gonna say I guess men no I guess
woman why
I don't know I feel like women are more
I like how his initial reaction was men
and then he's like oh wait I gotta say
women gotta say women
really intelligent
definitely understand like their
emotions and things that they care about
a little bit more than men I think men
because
they have to work more and so it says
chat type one a few things she should
give Nick a chance
look Nick wouldn't give me a chance you
know it's like
he's looking for the and he wants a girl
that's not annoying
I can't do that
you know it's
you know
yeah I wish him well in his rally I'm a
big Nick Fuentes like I mean
not with everything right not with
everything but I think he's funny and
I've been tweeting tweeting a lot so
yeah anyways
like they have a lot more going on in
their head
so they have a lot more they have to
like
take accountability for it and
responsibility and
They Don't Really argue much at least
from what I've seen what was the last
mistake you took accountability for
um you know I blamed my boyfriend and I
take accountability for blaming him
so just now
when was the last time you apologized
I'm sorry when was the last time you
apologized
um I'm sorry okay I always take part in
my in any problem regardless even if
someone did something to me I always
take my part of the blame is like I put
myself in the situation you know and I
feel like that's the only way we learned
how to grow is by taking accountability
for everything it takes two for
everything when someone commits a crime
do you blame the criminal or do you
blame society
the criminal you can always make your
own decisions at the end of the day both
it's nature nurtures okay that's such a
good okay it's complicated comes up with
the best questions because
we
we really we like talked about this
yesterday about like women being hoes
and like whose fault is it like I just
feel like it's your own fault pick your
lot in life you know what I mean it's
like
whatever decisions you make it's it's
you should be responsible for them
however however
it's always society's fault you don't
know what she what situation she was in
I'm like you can go get a job at Subway
just like the men get out of here
anyways you're a raise your mindset your
own individual actions I think all of
that matters I don't think they're
mutually exclusive
um if they're impoverished and it led to
them stealing food
then I don't blame them for their crime
I blame society because of the system
that we have in capitalism has failed
them
um whereas if they were to murder
capitalism you have so much opportunity
it's crazy I know people in other
countries where there's like actually
little opportunity you're so lucky to be
born here in all honesty see then that's
a different story well I'm in the I feel
like sometimes when I say here I'm in
the U.S I'm in the UK I want to go home
I want to go home so bad in this home
I blame society because I feel like
Society in a way they
cost the criminal to be a criminal
I mean a criminal doesn't have criminal
doesn't become a criminal overnight
something must have occurred in their
lives that would make them do crimes
make them want to do something
I cheat can he blame society
no if
it's complicated coming in with the kill
with the kill Jesus
how is that different than a criminal I
mean if someone does wrong why are you
more likely to blame
Society than blame the individual
because for society it takes it takes up
over time usually a criminal in my
opinion it doesn't happen overnight like
I said well if a guy cheats why can't he
just blame hookup culture
I mean like
he could but then like how long how long
would that occur like how well okay if a
guy cheats if a guy cheats can he blame
society or public culture absolutely not
I don't even have to finish hearing the
rest of that if a guy cheats he cannot
blame society there's you've made that
choice and that's where that
accountability comes in so if you make a
choice to commit to somebody but if a
woman cheats the first question the
first question is well
why did she cheat nobody cares why
nobody cares
Pearl keep fighting the good fight thank
you thank you Joyce to commit and follow
through if you're ready to step out the
door you can make that choice to be
respectful and to say hey you know what
I respect you and elf and I love you
guys I don't think I can watch that
rally on YouTube
if I was on Rumble maybe I don't know
how to stream on Rumble
but I think I need to get
a bigger follow so go follow me on
Rumble also oh my gosh I need to get
this form in the chat
um
I need to take you guys off so you can't
see my screen
if you would like to be on my email list
I'm going to start doing uh meetups in
London there will be Securities you know
weird stuff all right no weird stuff but
um I just would like to make a community
like-minded people that
we can do events with and I'm also going
to drop whale merch semi soon so I'm
gonna put that in the chat
freaking
but the whale merch I don't think we can
put on normal
on like normal streaming platforms
because let me see
why doesn't it
but you can put in your email phone
number if you want I know people are
weird about their phone numbers but you
can also just put in you know
you should make a whale hat oh my gosh
so many designs okay
um let me go back here that this isn't
going to work out as a monogamous
relationship I've got to go elsewhere
why is it when a man cheats he's a
cheater but when a woman cheats it's
because she's not satisfied
if you cheat you're a cheater if you're
a man or a woman I mean isn't a man not
satisfied when he's cheating I mean like
it's not black or white but it is has
been statistically proven that women
cheat for different reasons as opposed
to men for men it's more like sexual
gratification and for women it's more
like emotional gratification see it's
like she's justifying it
I think we understand the words that
come out of our mouth so it's a good
topic to cover is how long man to wait
for sex although it's not everything it
is a necessity I had to break it off
second because of the sexlessness well
well
there's two theories that we got going
here and it's tough because as a woman
I've never courted a woman
you know so take this with a grain of
salt but
it's like a good the idea is always
if she really wants to sleep with you
she's gonna sleep with you
if she doesn't then she won't and if
she's making you jump through a bunch of
Hoops she probably doesn't want want to
that bad unless she's a genuine good
girl
and that
it's the caveat but both are not true
and not honest with each other and
that's really what matters is just what
about a meet up in the U.S yeah I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna go to the US in
like a month or two I'm gonna do a meet
up probably Miami
um La maybe Vegas
um but for real there's gonna be
security no weird stuff no weird stuff
Communication in general
is it possible to have equality without
equal accountability oh no yeah no how
can men and women ever be equal if
relationships have double standards
that's a really tough thing because I
mean our society is built off of we we
live in a patriarchal society where men
have rolled for a really long time so
it's really hard to
um do that because double standards why
do we assume they ruled because it's
kind of like if someone's a CEO of a
company we don't think that they were in
charge for no reason that they just like
well I guess kind of feminists kind of
do but you know what I'm saying we don't
just automatically think that if
someone's a CEO of a company that they
got there for no reason but for some
reason with men
people just think they got into the
positions they're in for no reason for
creating in our society by men you
should host a Nick Destiny debate I
invited Destiny to box
okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna message him again
destiny
where
so
so is that a no
I'm
yeah okay the only thing is
why is it when men do wrong it's men's
fault but when women do wrong it's
society's fault I think women just try
to put the blame on other people
um
that's something that like I find myself
working on a lot because I do see it a
lot in the world what are women
exclusively held accountable for
oh I'm not exclusively held accountable
for just women
I'm not sure I can't think of anything
can you think of any problems in society
that aren't blamed on men
[Music]
oh my God that's such a
session no it's true because I was
thinking like women being hoes but no
they blame that on men
what are women exclusively held
accountable for
what are women uh nothing exclusively
held accountable for uh
I guess you know keeping keeping their
shirts on that's a good question I
really have no answer for that I think
we're not really held accountable for
anything and everything gets blamed on
men can you think of any problems in
society that aren't blamed on men
I mean women can't blame men for like
periods and stuff oh okay okay yeah but
they have the tampon tags they still
will blamed on men
I mean I'm sure tons but like at the end
of the day like
the society was kind of founded and
built by men so I feel like they should
take accountability like this is the
society that you built why would we
expect yeah but then shouldn't they have
the power that comes with it like the
video guys guys how many how many likes
are on this eh let's see let's see we
need to get
we need to get like two 300 likes in
here all right I feel like that is fair
a like is free today's my off day I'm
streaming on my off day how how nice to
me trying to have emotional well-being
in a society that always blames men I
don't think anybody cares about men
having a good emotional well-being and
that's the pro that's the main thing
like nobody cares
if men are blamed for Building Society
why are they never credited for anything
good in society because it's um I did I
did invite ab and preach I believe I did
to the boxing Max match sorry
um
way to doing content or a boxing match
it it's like Destiny did I stutter
as I said I said so is that a no because
I said I hope this isn't
I don't like to air out people's
messages so I hope he's not mad about
this
but I don't think you would be but I
said is that a no way to doing content
or a boxing match a boxing did I stutter
boxing
you versus Nick
one liberal no liberals will say yes I
got so many so many freaking
conservatives
hmm
oh wait let me turn the monetization on
on this we gotta get to
um okay uh expect it
what determines which problems you blame
others for versus problems you blame
yourself oh someone said Destiny's
friends with Abba can you ask Abba and
preach
can you ask Abba and preach Donovan says
he's down
come on guys let me host oh [__] let me
host a boxing match
guys I can't react to Nick at YouTube
I'm not I'm not gonna you would blame
others
for situations where you were misled and
you blame yourself for something which
you did on your own with no influence
whatsoever is it fair for
oh my God I'm dying
oh my God I'm so sorry I'm so sorry guys
oh my God I died
oh
my God
Jesus all right
to blame society for the consequences of
our own personal choices like having a
baby or choosing a career that over
sexualizes her body definitely not like
I I'm a webcam model and so something
that I do is sexualizing my body but I'm
not ever going to blame somebody else
for sexualizing me when I put myself out
there
thank you they like okay
honestly
what irritates me is the hose getting
triggered that they're hoes and for the
outcomes the hose oh my God if you want
to be a hoe I mean I still think it's
Haram I still think it's a degeneracy
right but like you know if you're gonna
do that fine what
irritates me what irritates me is when
the hoes want to do house [__] and not
have whole outcomes people are going to
call you about I respect it I almost the
girls that were tweeting on me when I
said strippers are
um hoes
oh wait wait oh wait we got a bite we
got a butt hold on sorry I respected the
girls that were kind of being like yeah
I am a hoe here's my link you know I
respect that when I don't respect
is the ones getting mad about the
outcomes okay
um destiny
is this wrong I don't
if we did when would it be
um
fall
it depends
how long it takes to plan
I'd say fall
late
fall
I need
some
I need a liberal
all right we'll see we'll see okay
make a need to make a shirt shirt that
says make shame and accountability great
again
would you buy that shirt put a one in
the chat one in the chat oh also guys
um let me put it this again get on our
email list I'm trying to make a freaking
email list because I have not gathered
people's emails and we are working on
that so here email list sign up
okay
is it when women are called out on their
bad behavior they often blame society or
how they're raised but when men are
called out they're more likely to be
held accountable
because it's an easy out for women to do
that
um to blame others but at the end of the
day it's your own decisions because it's
too easy for women they're feminine they
can cry all they do is cry and they're
like okay well you guys are wrong it
doesn't matter if they're in the wrong
I've seen chicks cheat and then they'll
cry and their guys will take them back
and I'm like she cheated on you
I don't think that men are held
accountable as often as they should
um but again this past experiences
um but I think that
because I guess I'm gonna crack my neck
I know this is gonna be gross but it
just it hurts I'm gonna I'm sorry I'm
sorry
okay I'm done I'm done uh the whole like
me too movement it's so easy for women
to fall back on that as an excuse It's
not necessarily that they shouldn't be
held accountable for their own actions
it's more so that the media has made it
really easy for them to use it as a
scapegoat I think there's harsher
punishment on women for a lot of these
reasons and also Society has been built
to sustain men and cisgender men
straight white men so it's like they can
be called out on certain things but it's
not as harsh punishment as like women or
like black women if women can blame all
their shortcomings on patriarchy and
internalized misogyny does that absolve
them from all personal responsibility
no they think it does but it shouldn't
it doesn't absolve them of personal
based Girl based responsibility because
um ultimately it's their responsibility
to
um do good things for themselves but yes
it's it I think it's important to
to at least acknowledge that misogyny
and Patriot and living in a patriarchal
society that they are um at a place of
disadvantage if you check the Forbes
billionaires list the real times
billionaires list it's it's probably a
hundred women in like three
thousand dudes
why are women more concerned with the
ratio and how did those females and then
how did those women get the money
they're husbands those as opposed to the
ratio of lower paid dangerous dirty jobs
done mostly by men because they're less
willing to do those dangerous Dirty Jobs
and they want the CEO money
how do you personally decide which
social pressures you conform to and
which ones you reject
what I mean depends on your religion
your culture your environment your
family I feel like as a parent I have
teenagers and guys I need 300 likes in
here 300 come on double-edged sword
right there's things that we need to
conform to that we everyone wants to fit
in everyone wants to be loved everyone
wants to be accepted but there are
things that when you have certain
standards they might not necessarily be
the cool thing or the end thing
for everyone else out there and so I
decide on how it makes me feel is it
something that is going to build me up
and make me a better individual if I do
it is it something that can is gonna
hurt somebody if it is going to hurt
somebody
I don't do it like I think try to think
of other people when I am choosing my
choices who is more likely to care what
Society thinks men or women women
for sure who's more likely to follow
Trends women
why would women care what Society thinks
if we're living in a world that
oppresses them we're not
he is so good at questions I wish I was
this good at coming up with questions
oh wow
thing in a world that oppresses women
quite the opposite in fact thank you
based Woman based based thank you okay
all right not at this point
2023 where we at 2020 women don't give a
damn about stuff we got BBL oh my gosh I
just thought of something I wanted to
react to okay so great video It's
Complicated
let's I wanted to react to me on the
vice feminism panel
I don't know if Sydney if someone can
get a hold of Sydney tell her to call in
on this because
let me tell you let me tell you they cut
out so much
oh my gosh they cut out so much they cut
out
freaking
we were there for six hours they made
this down to 45 minutes
45 minutes
how is it sexism when we have no
barriers today so we can we can pick and
then they're gonna have the lady with no
legs
the question I should have asked oh
anyways women don't have barriers women
yeah we have no you can do whatever you
want oh my gosh this was so irritating
you know I'm not talking about your
goddamn wheelchair you know I'm not
talking about your wheelchair so could
we stop
I don't even call Nick
call Nick
Watson got mogged by Nick anyways
huh
hmm
guys I can't
um I I can't react him on YouTube I'm
I'm not you guys are not gonna get me
taken down uh I can or you can what's
stopping you
oh I have a wheelchair [__]
you know damn well that I was not
talking about your goddamn wheelchair
call snico
okay first I was calling Nick now I'm
calling sneako
um
okay well why don't you tell whoever I'm
supposed to call
oh oh you guys are trying to get me off
of here I was like why
all right
bring it
guys I can't magically bring in another
content creator that's in a different
country
this is that this is asking a lot all
right
should we mark this bad boy at all
here we go hi welcome everybody I'm Liz
Landers I'm Vice news's Chief political
correspondent and we are here today to
talk about some of the biggest issues
dividing women across the country in
other words we're here to talk about
feminism
first I just want to say we know we
can't represent everybody's views but we
did try our best to bring together a
diverse group of women today in today's
polarized world is feminism dead
you guys saw your hand I think that the
pencil and definition of feminism
I strongly think that feminism is more
of an action than an identity I wouldn't
say it's uplifting all women in which
case it's very alive at the same time if
we do follow that definition feminism
has splintered off into so many
different areas that you can look at
people like Cheryl Sandberg who say you
should just get another Nanny if you
feel oppressed and if we're talking
about that kind of feminism
um yeah it's pretty dead yeah I mean as
long as a human race exists feminism
feminism will never be dead there's
something that we're going to have to
strive and work I'll tell you where it
is dead
Ukraine
sorry sorry all right
work towards
um call bench you think I got Ben's
number
you make sure that there's equality so
feminism is not dead I don't know that
it can die as long as there's power and
oppression there will be people fighting
for equity and
um until that somehow goes away feminism
is Alive and Well I think feminism isn't
actually about equality it's about
equality when it benefits us I think
feminism
it's really about women wanting special
privileges and treatment
at the expense of then often and I think
it's alive and well sadly yeah I knew I
was like I know half the room is just
gonna I knew what I was there to do
advice when I it was funny this was a
really really quick like I was called
out to this really quick
um it was like a week before a week and
a half and they're like yeah we'll fly
you out to New York whatever and I'm
like cool
bring me over baby and it was funny I
knew I got the the the
role because this girl is asking me all
these questions you could tell this girl
was super liberal and she was like
asking me about about my opinions and I
was like yeah I question if women should
vote
and when I said that
that was when um
that was that was one freaking I knew I
was gonna get called out there okay
I think feminism is also alive and well
um there are different kinds of feminism
right like that is obvious
um and sorry a dog snoring if you hear
something I for me as a womanist as a
black feminist right as someone who's
really thinking about human rights
dignity right Equity right as long as
that's not that need is a met we're
still going to keep fighting I'd say
it's alive and well I'd say that it's
also very nuanced and I think what it
looks like is going to differ depending
on where you are in the world for me I
just see it as a lens which isn't
necessarily antagonistic or uh
protagonistic it's just a useful tool
similar to what Pearl just said I find
that a lot of feminist ideology and
thought today feels more of like a
supremacist movement rather than
something that is supposed to be
advancing the goals of equality I don't
think that we can really turn what's
going on as feminism because it looks so
different to I think the earlier
feminist movement so in that way I would
say it's taken its last breaths of life
it's dying yeah I definitely think it's
getting more and more radicalized for
sure so it's it's definitely still alive
I think I'll preface and say that I
don't know so much about modern Western
feminism and there might be a lot of
terms that I don't know know like
political jargon and stuff
[__] did you grow up in America or not
like oh shoot
let me
hold on sorry my phone fell it's just
like what do you mean you're not
familiar do you live here do you maybe
maybe she doesn't I don't know
I don't know
but I believe in the advancement of
women whoever considers themselves a
woman I think I believe in the
advancement of smart people all right I
don't care if you're a man or woman but
if we're going to talk about like
advancement and Society deserving more
whatever
let's bring back the smart people
efficiency in society so it's deeply
rooted that feminism has always existed
I think America's a little obsessed with
themselves and like always feminism is
rooted in America and like oh white
women started it and it's kind of
offensive because for thousands of years
women have been dying for their rights I
think as a black woman specifically uh
when you talk about feminism yeah the
mainstream first thing you think about
is a certain type of feminism that tends
to exclude still even today even with
intersectional feminism exclude
African-American women and it's always
kind of done that and also upper middle
class white women has predominantly been
the face of what we quote unquote
consider feminism
I think feminism is attempting to say
okay the first thing we agree on is that
there are barriers in friction to what I
need and what I want based on the fact
that I'm a woman what it ignores is that
and what privilege is is that you may
not have to think that being a woman and
being a black woman and being a black
woman who has a disability for example
impacts you further you have more
barriers you have more friction you are
less able to get what you want you're
undervalued in a way that's like
okay well you know that's life that's
what I mean by equity and that we're
able to without friction all get the
same needs met yeah
um yep yeah see I disagree with that I
think life is easier if you're a girl
yep
um actually I think I think there's a
lot of benefits um that men don't have
thank you
thank you for Notre Dame but thank you
she's like you can use it as an
advantage if you want to yes ma'am I'm
not going to speak anything to race I'm
just talking about gender specifically
it's usually like an excuse like
honestly I think as a girl you have
equal opportunity in the world I think
there's benefits like for example we
have quotas for women in specific jobs
that are given to us that aren't given
to men so yeah I would say it's easier
being a girl just from a Viewpoint over
here though it seems there's a lot of
privilege pretty privilege in what
you're saying
thank you
and then and then all the Liberals are
just like oh
you're so ugly that's all the the lib
reactions did and I'm like guys all
right if I'm ugly and I wouldn't go for
you what is that what is that look at
and that you're white and you present do
you think I'm pretty thank you
thank you
you presented in a way that beauty
standards have accepted and so they call
me ugly on the internet all the time
yeah and that's it okay people thought
this is like an insecure thing guys it's
just like when I went for the whales all
right when I went after the whales when
I was going hard on whales when it was
whale season I was wailing all of these
you know what's funny my mom she's
always like don't call them whales but
every time I say it she laughs
no no no no
um
for the thing they all made these videos
like hundreds of videos just calling me
ugly blah blah blah
baby roasted me daily I swear to God I
don't mean to say I think you're Gorge I
just mean that there are a certain value
that we give to certain bodies I mean
let's also I mean if you if you said I
have a nice body just say that just say
that
anyways to why these quotas exist and
why these um what you're calling because
they're just a special treatment
um no it's because they're have
historically and presently and most jobs
been fewer women because of sexism how
is it sexism when we have no barriers
today so we can we can pick nobody
oh my gosh
women it's like these people pretend to
be
they pretend they don't know what I'm
saying they know what I'm saying
whatever you want uh I can or you can no
I have no legs it's just you
Woman as a woman as a woman as a woman
as a woman
I regret what I wish I said
what is stopping you
that wouldn't stop a man in your same
position
I'm waiting nothing there's a lot
stopping me that you don't have to the
staircases
well as I said before I'm speaking about
women you're speaking as you're speaking
for yourself you're speaking as a body
woman woman
of course of course there's going to be
other barriers if you're disabled I'm
sure like I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm
talking about as a woman so you're just
gonna ignore it no
no
Vice why did you do me like this
okay advice YouTube Let me back up
let me back up I'm sorry
I'm sorry
can I come back on
how do I get back on
okay let's see if I can restart is this
stream back on
guys I'm sorry I'm sorry why God